i know she have on a hurley shirt today
naya used to give you grave about those
hurley shirts didn't she
yeah they're actually the hurley
t-shirts i've got an assortment of them
she said you know if you're coming to a
wedding reception or if you're coming to
something else
please don't wear that hurley it was
kind of that
back and forth where yes you have a
daughter and you're the parent
but she was also had grown into your
friend yeah
we had a really good relationship um you
know
father-daughters relationships always go
sideways
maybe it's from the advice you give them
but you know as they're growing up
they're listening to you and listening
to you and at some point it's like
really what do you know
and those are dynamics that we had to
overcome and i think we overcame that
really well
into a respectful friendship partnership
she always came back to me about
maturity things that she needed to to
learn about
and when she started having a child
that was a big moment what did josie
mean to her
he he really became everything for her
right her focus
her focus was really on on him
and as he was
growing up as she was becoming a mother
she she really leaned into that
the word i want to use is maturity
became very mature as a person
and and really receptive to other
people's feelings
how do you talk to him about his mama
and i see that he asks about his mama
all the time
he does i'll tell you um nakayla and
ryan are doing a really great job
right tough situation um
especially because he was there it's not
like you're talking about a ghost that's
floating around right
he's got memories as well but boy is he
is he coming around right really strong
kid
um we we handle him and we talk to him
just like he's a five-year-old going on
sex
it's no different but when he wants to
talk about his mother we talk about his
mother
in conversation he's growing up and
handling it really well
the way nicolas stepped in and helped
take care of josie
in such an amazing way what does that
mean to you
michaela is an amazing individual right
she's got a lot of love for her sister
very close
there were media outlets that said oh
eyebrows are raised when she moved in
with ryan and
really she was just doing the best thing
for josie though yeah that's right
that had to irritate you a little bit
not at all no
not at all remember i'm used to
paparazzi not me myself but i'm used to
hearing about the propabarazzi
i'm used to hearing about people's
opinions
that didn't bother me at all because we
knew we were doing the right thing
and um that's what we did
how's ryan doing ryan's good he's
working he's
a great father just a really great
father you learn a lot about people and
you learn a lot about relationships
when you go through something like this
i couldn't thank ryan enough for the
father that he's become
hmm you think about
mothers will do anything for their child
and
she used her last breath to make sure
that he was
okay what does that say to you sort of
the same mantra she used for life you
know preservation
keep going when things are hard you keep
pushing
right it just shows you the strength of
the person you talked about
face timing with her that day yeah
that's that's that was that was a hard
day
that was a hard day she called me up
when she was on the boat and she was
looking for
a place to dock and
i'm an avid boater kids have always been
in the water
you know i haven't told the story a lot
but i got a real sinking feeling because
i'm in tennessee face timing with her at
least piraou
and i was just trying to advise her hey
you know you got to know how the boat
drifts you got to know the lake you have
to understand
you know that you're with josie and you
guys just got to be in a safe place and
if it doesn't have an anchor
you don't want the boat to drift away
from you and then the phone
cut off and i don't know why we even got
reception
because when i went to lake pyrou zero
reception on the phone
so i don't know if it was divine
intervention or what it was but
uh i could see how you know the swells
on
on on the lake and how difficult it was
you took a picture that day of the
facetime didn't you i did
do you look at it often and what do you
think about when you look at it i i
couldn't look at it for nine months
right
in fact i couldn't look at any pictures
for naya for nine months
i just recently going through this
process we're going through now
talking about her a little bit is the
only time that i've been able
to look at some pictures
and the only reason i can look at
pictures is i can look at the celebrity
pictures
because that doesn't identify you know
my daughter
but trying to look at intimate pictures
is really difficult
was it normal for ny to go out on a boat
by herself with just
her son her young son
that wasn't normal because she she
didn't own a boat so
she wouldn't have done that on a normal
period but
if going out on outings things like that
absolutely she had she had a lot of
moments where she
she would just sporadically go somewhere
with josie and do something
she was familiar and comfortable with
the water yes we were boating family and
how does an accident like this happen
when you're
so used to the wall you know i i have
the same questions
we're always jumping off the boat
swimming avid swimmers
it is it's a question all that final
face time do you remember anything
specific that you said
you know i really don't you know uh it's
such a blur
um i don't know if it's ptsd i don't
know
what it is right not that i choose to
remember it because there was something
important
said the the the the
what i do remember is we were laughing
and having a great time
that's how we conducted our life to be
as happy as possible
we were at the lake
there are certain moments i remember
that tug on your heart
and there is a picture of your wife with
her arm stretched out
and looking out at the lake what was
what were you saying at that moment you
didn't get the picture of me
jogging down the paparazzi picture of me
running down
diving into the middle i was going to
ask you about that too
that moment i needed to reconnect with
the water
i needed to reconnect to where she was
and my number one goal was finding her
and i didn't know how to do it except
for
getting in the water and having a moment
because at that moment we had you know
very very little hope
on what had happened how it happened
and if we were going to find her you've
been very active on twitter you also
been writing poetry
and other things and you wrote a letter
tonight how is that helping you is it
like a therapy well it's interesting i
didn't think that i could do it
and i went to a spot that i used to take
her to once in a while when she was down
here
and i just said oh okay so i started
writing it and you know through the
tears and through the shaking
um i i was able to
i think expressed the emotions that i
had for her
and then in closure in the letter
i also came to terms with
you won't be back here i know i won't
see you again
but me michael and michaela
we have josie we've taken care of him
he'll be fine
will you do me a favor will you read
this letter
nya my beautiful daughter i'm writing
this letter to you this father's day
2021 as i'm sitting here on the ocean
cliffs and carlsbad by the single lone
dead tree
where i took you many times as an adult
when you came to visit me
i'm looking out at the vast ocean sea
crying over the love that i have for you
shaking not being able to laugh with you
or hug you or hearing your sarcastic
quips about my hurley shirts
don't worry michaela still has that
cover
i miss you terribly even though we
sometimes didn't see eye to eye
he always came back to me and i you
[Music]
you're not coming back this time
like i'm used to you doing but our love
for each other remains the same
this father's day i'm going to celebrate
your life with me and the greatest
moments that we spent together
and i wanted to let you know the things
i feel for you
and how proud i am for you how proud i
am for you
the daughter and mother you became
[Music]
it's been so long since i've been able
to tell you you're the joy
i feel when i remember how we used to
bond over music and singing
the hard time when rejection came to our
lives professionally
and personally when i told you at 15
years old about boys and men
what you were going that you were going
to have
a hard time because of the type of
person you are driven
mature intense about your goals and path
in life
you made me so proud of you when i took
you to venice at 17 and you got up on
stage to sing at that open mic with all
those adults in the room
looking at you with judgment in their
eyes
you were nervous and hesitant but you
believed in me
and my confidence in you and you did it
you killed that song
you listened to my advice and went
forward through every obstacle that came
your way
remember when you graduated high school
i said well college is next you looked
at me and said yeah sure
you had a plan and a goal in mind and
nothing stopped you
i guess you knew what you were after
i'm so proud that you didn't let the
pressures of those teenage years break
your spirit to achieve your goals
i think about those times together in
the recording
studios again with those adults telling
you what you should
and shouldn't do you had your own agenda
i also remember telling you about my
teenage days in the 70s
so you knew that i wasn't perfect either
your beautiful son josie is strong
healthy and happy
he's growing up and he's been taken care
of just like you did
he knows you're okay and watching over
him rest assured
um and he talks about you all the time
mama thank you for caring for me your
brother and sister
keep sleeping soundly my angel and we'll
take it from here
i love you and miss you but i know you
know that
love dad
i don't even believe i wrote that
why not it's um
it's emotions that are you know really
deep
deep emotions for someone you really
love and you wish they were still here
and they're just not um but it's a
coming to terms
right whatever that means it's just
coming to terms
the line keeps sleeping soundly my angel
and we'll we'll take it from here
what do you want nya's legacy to be she
didn't finish what she started
in terms of what she wanted to do maybe
with her voice
with her platform with her talent with
her skill set
um but i wanted her to understand
i feel a connection i feel that
connection with her and i wanted her to
understand
that we're not only okay you know
we're going to take on the challenges of
life and the challenges of
helping raise your my grandchild your
child
with the same sort of satisfaction vim
and vigor that you had
that's why i wrote that line do you see
her in him
oh yeah oh yeah he he is uh
he's he's a healthy happy rambunctious
young man that you know has that spirit
uh he has that spirit of joy
i'm gonna ask you a hard question you
think back to that day
there's a replay in your head it used to
for about nine months eight or nine
months and still
until i started this process of
purging by by talking about nya
and celebrating her life um
i don't think back to that moment
i i really don't you know it's a
lifetime it's 33 years
yeah i think of the whole it's a 50 000
foot level
right i look at the whole whole life
span
and how much she gave to me i gave to
her
we gave each other as a family
it's really it's a joyous occasion
rather than a tragedy
right what do you want people to know
about nia
i think it's about sort of the strong
dynamic personality
and never giving up never giving up on
your
dream and your focus she knew she was
lucky
but she knew she worked hard for that
she didn't go out and try to be that
character
she tried to be naya and show
show people the best that that she had
always
[Music]
happy